brian as students get back into the
classroom ccsd is rolling out his plans
for spring sports
sports director chris matthews joining
us now in the studio with the plan for
clark county and also reaction chris
well thank you denisha with the governor
giving the thumbs up and superintendent
dr jesus jara's blessing
contact sports will soon be back at your
favorite ccsd campus
here's the plan now spring sports
practices begin in early april for a
variety of boys and girls sports
with competition beginning april 16th
for the intramural fall sports that had
to be adjusted because of covet
football will be back but not with games
but full contact competition
within each school basically a spring
football practice to get ready for the
2021
season other fall intramural sports may
take place in may
both boys and girls they've staggered
the sports so that students aren't
forced to choose a single sport and of
course
no fans allowed coaches and other adults
will have to test
negative before all activities well this
is a plan that has a blessing of the
niaa
and now with the reaction from the
coaches john treats joining us from the
newsroom and john
i'm assuming the activities boy a few
better than none
so true imagine being stranded in the on
deck circle for over a year not being
able to compete not being able to
chase a championship with your friends
and not being able to put on the earned
uniform
as a high school athlete while the rest
of the country does today las vegas kids
finally heard
play ball the players at desert oasis
high school felt like they've been
facing a two-strike count for two
straight seasons
the 2019 champions were denied a chance
to repeat two straight seasons
but today they received the good news
they worried would never come
the season is truncated the schedule is
compact the playoff system is limited
but
this spring southern nevada will have
baseball and all feels right
there's some very good baseball players
that that would have that played two
years at jv baseball that
that potentially could have not you know
put on a varsity uniform and play a
varsity game that
that are college athletes and and just
to have them be able to
you know no matter how long our season
is how short it is just to have them
the ability to have a senior day and to
have that experience of putting the
jersey on and having the walk-up song
at first it was kind of hard you know or
during the fall to keep
myself and the boys motivated but uh
you know we kept working and now we have
to go to play a season so
you know everyone's ready and it's a
great feeling i found out
when i was driving actually a couple
hours ago i was pretty pumped about it
being able to play baseball for the
first time in two years
and tripp is one of the many kids who
will get to play varsity sports for the
first time this spring he's a senior
and now he can say hard work pays off
brian
so great to hear that for those kids
john